[Musica]
che cosa è successo qui
perché ci sono tutti i pupazzi a terra
Forse è stato Merlino
luce di cibo
[Musica]
Vitale
che vuole patate arrosto
siamo qui nel forno
Vitale
Perché ridi così
Che cosa hai combinato io che cosa ho
combinato io Eh sì io ero giù Quindi
vuoi dirmi che non sei stato tu a
mangiare il pacco intero di merendine e
vediamo cos'altro c'è
le patatine
I taralli non sei stata tu a mangiarli
No ma non sono stato io davvero e chi
può essere stato No non sono stato io Ma
perché devi dare la colpa a me Magari è
stato Merlino Merlino
non riesci
facendo tutto questo tempo io stavo
controllando le patate nel forno
[Musica]
Quanto ci impiegano ancora
Quindi se non sei stato tu può essere
stato solo Merlino potremmo fare una
cosa chiamiamo Merlino e vediamo se ha
la faccia Colpevole mi sembra un'ottima
idea vado subito a chiamarlo e vediamo
che reazione fa
Ciao ragazzi Bentornati su Anita Stories
Secondo voi chi è stato a fare questo
disastro Secondo me è stato vitale solo
che non lo vuole ammettere lo scopriremo
molto presto assieme se non avete ancora
lasciato un mi piace Mi raccomando
lasciate un mi piace entro cinque
secondi cinque quattro Tre due uno tempo
scaduto se non mi seguite ancora su
Instagram andate a seguirmi il nome
Anita Stories e se volete Seguitemi
anche su Tik Tok il nome è sempre Anita
Stories Ma quanto ci mette Vitale ad
arrivare con Merlino
ah ah
vediamo un po'
Merlino sei stato tu
Merlino Oggi stavo cercando di mangiare
un pupazzo Merlino vediamo un po'
Merlino Chi è stato no Merlino No no non
si mangia
Merlino prova proprio mangiare il gatto
sei stato tu
Merlino non sembra avere la faccia da
colpevole
Merlino Sai dirmi chi è stato a fare
questa hai visto qualcuno
mi sa che lui è colpevole Guarda come si
annusa tutte le carte io non mi sembra
colpevole avrebbe fatto la sua faccia
colpevole cioè il suo muso colpevole
Quindi io penso proprio che ci sia solo
un colpevole Sì guarda un po' Guarda chi
è il colpevole
Merlino Ma che fai così
Ma quindi sei stato tu non lo so mica
questo Eh non me lo racconta giusta ma
neanche tu me la racconti giusta
non mi sembra che sia stato Merlino ma
nemmeno Vitale mi sembra abbastanza
sincero chi può essere stato Allora non
so a chi credere C'è qualcuno là dietro
C'è qualcuno là dietro Merlino No è solo
il pupazzo che vuoi mangiarti quindi non
siete stati né tu né Merlino ma a me
tocca comunque mettere a posto tutto
questo disastro Guarda io ti giuro che
non sono stato Peccato che non puoi
chiederlo alle patate te lo
confermerebbero che sono stato tutto il
tempo a guardarle quanto a Merlino
Invece lui era fuori tutto questo tempo
Questo è il tempo in giardino
Beh in effetti questo è molto strano
[Musica]
sembra qualcosa al piano di sotto non lo
so meglio andare a controllare subito
però Ok andiamo Merlino Vieni con noi
aspetta prendiamo qualcosa per
difenderci nel caso che sia un mostro
molto cattivo io ho scelto questa e io
ho scelto questa qui andiamo
[Musica]
Merlino fai piano
non vedo nessuno qua
tu Merlino vedi qualcuno
prova ad annusare con il tuo naso
Merlino
ha un po' di sonno un'idea Proviamo a
vedere se c'è delle impronte o qualche
traccia da seguire ok
ci sono delle briciole da dove arrivano
iniziano proprio da qua Forse partivano
dalla cucina laggiù
Vitale
Sì sono delle tracce Guarda parlano da
quella parte
dove arrivano
queste briciole un topo o delle formiche
è impossibile le formiche non lasciano
così tante briciole deve essere stato
una creatura un po' sbadata Quindi o tu
o Merlino Ti giuro non sono stato io
magari a qualcuno che somiglia a noi due
ma non lo so Vabbè Seguiamo le tracce e
vediamo
Allora
partono da qua
e
arrivano passano proprio sotto il divano
guarda Si interrompono qua è vero sarà
qua dentro allora
Quindi se si interrompono qua la
creatura o L'animale è sicuramente qua
dentro però qui
così
chi è
È una battuta c'è nessuno
mi sa che non c'è nessuno Allora
facciamo annusare Merlino
lasciata Dall'altro la triciato no
Merlino
[Musica]
dove sono a nuotare qua e vedere se c'è
una creatura qua dentro è troppo tardi
Merlino sta mangiando tutto cosa c'è qua
dentro Controlla
Ah Merlino non gliene frega proprio
niente di cosa potrebbe esserci qua
dentro vuole solo sgranocchiare visto
che Merlino non ci aiuta l'unico modo
per scoprire cosa è entrato in casa e
aprire questo cassetto Ma teniamoci
pronti con le nostre armi al mio via
apriamo il cassetto Ok io copriamo cos'è
pronti 5 4 3 2 1 via
Che cosa c'è dentro no Merlino Stai
attento Ma non mi sembra di vedere
niente come niente non c'è niente
all'interno oppure se l'è già mangiato
Merlino o non c'è niente per davvero non
c'è niente
Ma come è possibile che le tracce
finivano qua se non c'è niente dentro e
forse si è nascosto là dentro per
mangiare tutto o è scappato all'ultimo
momento
mi è venuto un'idea Guarda lassù
la nostra camera di sicurezza
possiamo guardare le camere di sicurezza
che registrano sempre così siamo a
vedere chi è entrato in casa Che cos'è
Che animale è Ok andiamo subito a
vederlo e Sono troppo curiosa di
scoprire che cos'è Merlino Chi è stato
secondo te entrare in casa tu l'hai
visto ok ragazzi Stiamo per vedere le
registrazioni delle camere di sicurezza
Mettetevi comodi e ricordatevi di
lasciare un bel mi piace su questo video
Pronti Via Ok Ecco la registrazione del
salotto
è Merlino
in salotto Ecco che cos'è un rumore che
abbiamo sentito Allora quindi forse è
stato Merlino a mangiare quelle cose a
buttare giù i pupazzi non è entrato
nessuno
continuiamo a vedere vediamo
qualcos'altro
lui è qui che si guarda intorno
Guarda è questo che cos'è
un coniglio no sembra più un gatto
camaleonte Allora
no sono attraversato il salotto forse un
porcellino d'India anche se ha le
orecchie un po' grandi Infatti sembra
più delle orecchie d'asino attaccato a
un porcellino d'India
continuiamo a guardare vediamo se si
vede meglio
Ah la cucina
come muove la testa
quando il cibo no si sta rubando il mio
cibo preferito le camere in camera da
letto ha buttato via tutti i peluche
quindi è stato questo strano animale
Eccola lui
bevitale Mi dispiace di averti incolpato
di tutte quelle cose avevo detto che non
sono stato io a mangiarmi tutte quelle
cose sì ma che animale è un topo un
gatto un furetto Che cos'è
ragazzi scrivete poi secondo voi Che
animale è perché Vitale ormai non
ragiona più visto che ha visto qualcuno
che gli rubava oggi è così e infatti mi
è venuta un'idea se noi guardiamo le
camere di sicurezza in diretta quindi
non la registrazione
realtà se riusciamo a capire dov'è
l'animaletto se si nasconde ancora in
casa nostra e in che stanza è per andare
a prenderlo e potrebbe essere da
qualsiasi parte Magari è proprio qua in
questa stanza che ci osserva Ok
controlliamo le camere in diretta
vediamo che stanza guardiamo prima
Ovviamente la cucina va bene ecco qua la
cucina sembra tutto tranquillo Sì non
c'è niente di strano
la camera da letto ok
Non c'è nessuno in corridoio
sembra tutto normale Per fortuna
si nasconde in un punto in cui le camere
di sicurezza non prendono
Guarda
c'è qualcosa che si muove qua sotto al
tavolo Lo vedi È lui sì e ora Nello
studio al piano di sopra Che facciamo
andiamo subito a prenderlo aspettiamo e
vediamo dove va vediamo prima dove va
magari esce fuori direttamente Ok si sta
muovendo Merlino
no Merlino non mangiarlo
Ok facciamo il corridoio
Merlino lo sta inseguendo
Oh no dici che parlano tanto
cambiamo visuale
Eccolo sta arrivando giù
[Musica]
che succede e come Merlino Sto cercando
di difenderci guardiamo le scale
è proprio qui allora
visto è passato dallo studio al
corridoio all'altro corridoio alle scale
quindi sta per arrivare qui proprio da
quella porta
sta scendendo
dovrebbe essere proprio dietro quella
porta
[Musica]
c'è nessuno
Merlino
Hai visto per caso quell'animaletto
Merlino l'hai visto da qualche parte
eh Ma vuoi vedere anche tu le camere di
sicurezza
Merlino si accomodato vuole vedere anche
lui le camere di sicurezza Merlino tu
l'hai visto meglio di tutti Ho visto che
l'hai rincorsa dai Merlino Dimmi dove è
andato così possiamo andare a prenderlo
Merlino non vuole vedere quello che a me
di sicurezza
Eppure strano è sceso qui dalle scale
assieme a lui
ma non Forse è meglio mettersi a
cercarlo è sceso qui non lo possiamo
lasciare qui a vagare da solo dobbiamo
metterci a cercarlo magari Dividiamoci
io controllo il salotto qua E tu cosa
vuoi controllare Ovviamente io vado a
controllare in cucina no mi sembra
proprio che è giusto Ok vai vai
non metterti a mangiare
io no
Merlino mi aiuti a cercare l'animaletto
vero mi aiuti
Comunque mi è venuta un'altra idea se
non riesco a trovarlo provo da tirarlo
con un po' di cibo proprio come faccio
con Vitale c'è Merlino Hai trovato
qualcosa
Merlino ho trovato qualcosa fammi vedere
che cos'è
no Merlino non si mangia
Ma che cosa vuol dire questo bigliettino
è molto strano è scritto in inglese c'è
scritto Ricordati delle regole evita le
luci molto forti non dargli da mangiare
dopo mezzanotte
non bagnarlo mai e poi sopra c'è scritto
una parola strana gismo
tra il nome dell'animaletto o forse è un
qualcosa in un'altra lingua bravissimo
Merlino che hai trovato questo indizio
sei il mio fedele aiutante è bravissimo
Ora cerca il resto cerca cerca cerca
cerca cerca cerca Merlino Cerca
[Musica]
mi sembra di vedere qualcosa laggiù vedi
Merlino
Bravo l'hai trovato anche tu Bravo
Merlino che ho trovato tutti gli indizi
e non lo sgranocchiare però Ok
Bravissimo Merlino me lo daresti per
favore
no
Oh
ma il fatto cadere dentro il cassetto
aspetta apro io il cassetto
Ok Preso
strano in questo biglietto praticamente
ci sono scritte quasi le stesse cose
tranne che c'è un'immagine con scritto
fragile forse questo animaletto è stato
trasportato in una scatola è stato
spedito da qualche parte attenzione
Ricordati delle regole niente luce forte
non dargli da mangiare dopo mezzanotte e
non bagnarli per nessun motivo ma perché
hanno ripetuto queste regole Vabbè
vediamo se c'è qualcos'altro in giro
Merlino ho trovato qualcosa
Che cosa hai trovato Merlino No ma
quello è l'indizio di prima Lo stai
distruggendo bene Merlino ha
sgranocchiato l'indizio di prima No no
non so più dove cercare questo
mostriciattolo
con gli indizi non volevano dire niente
[Musica]
Che cos'è questo suono
proviene da dietro al divano
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Che carino
Ma che animale sei
ti farò un bellissimo ritratto ecco
[Musica]
pennelli
tela
e
l'acqua per gli acquerelli
rimani fermo così ok
carino
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi piace proprio cantare
[Musica]
Cos'è questo
l'ho trovato aspetta
[Musica]
A lei piace tanto cantare quindi volevo
aspettare che finisse di cantare questo
è l'animaletto che si è mangiato tutto
il mio cibo Sì è proprio lui
e in realtà non lo so c'era Questo
biglietto in cui c'è scritto che è un
gismo o un Gremlin qualcosa del genere
ma non è troppo carino
Si mangia il mio cibo come fa ad essere
carino
morbidissimo è vero È tanto carino però
si mangia tutto il mio cibo e voi non
possiamo mica tenerlo così dobbiamo
vedere Dobbiamo chiedere a Merlino se è
d'accordo è d'accordo
Merlino sembra d'accordo Mmm Merlino sei
d'accordo a tenere il ritmo
A me sembra che abbia detto di sì Ora
lasciami un momento in pace che devo
fare il suo ritratto Grazie Merlino
Merlino ha accettato di avere un nuovo
fratellino e cioè gismo evitare la luce
troppo forte non dargli da mangiare dopo
mezzanotte e non bagnarlo mai Sì sì va
bene va bene ora vai e io devo fare il
ritratto ciao ciao ciao
ancora un momento di Smooth quasi finito
il tuo ritratto Però promettimi di non
offenderti Ok non sei proprio uguale
Ok ho finito Sei pronto
3 2 1
ti piace perché non dici niente
Forse vuoi vederlo un po' più da vicino
non ti piace
Oh no l'ho bagnato devo andare subito a
prendere qualcosa per asciugarlo
[Musica]
che succede
gismo
[Musica]
siete due
un altro
è stata tutta colpa mia li ho bagnati
con l'acqua cioè l'ho bagnato e sono
diventati due
questo è proprio un bel guaio devo
subito nasconderlo prima che arrivi
l'Italia Berlino Mi raccomando tu non
hai visto niente Ok
non se ne accorgerà mai vero
no no no no no no qua
l'ho nascosto qua mi raccomando Merlino
Non dire niente a Vitale ok E il nostro
segreto
Quale segreto niente intendevo dire che
Merlino è un segreto cioè che ha
mangiato
[Musica]
ha mangiato Hai mangiato il mio maglione
con il tuo padrone Bravo Merlino
che cosa vi devo dire No non ti niente
torna pure in cucina
siamo Tu sì che sai tenere i segreti
ma che noi non abbiamo nessun segreto
ovvero Merlino
stavamo solo giocando
niente no no no no no niente Non sta
facendo niente
Ma cos'è quello non c'è niente qua
dietro Fammi vedere
se non c'è niente da nascondere perché
strano non c'è niente
Eppure te l'ho detto che non c'è niente
di averne visto un altro come può
essercene un altro lo so forse ho avuto
questa stranissima illusione ottica che
cosa nasconde dietro niente Merlino sta
cercando di dirti qualcosa Merlino vuoi
uscire Vuoi uscire
No no aspetta allontanati Merlino sta
cercando di dirmi dietro
non c'è niente Non ci credo mi stai
nascondendo qualcosa che cos'è Fammi
vedere Merlino si sta nasconde
ndo cosi è buono È gentilissimo Dove
stai scappando
dove sarà andata a nascondersi o
quell'altro chilismo Merlino
Dov'è padroncina
di qua Mmm vediamo
che cosa ci fai nascosta qua dietro con
dualismo come hanno fatto a diventare
due
non lo so io cioè in realtà penso di
saperlo Dai vieni ti spiego Praticamente
stavo dipingendo un ritratto di chismo
sì bellissimo
casa non ho capito
Bravissimo
mi è caduta l'acqua
Ti ricordi che una delle regole era di
non bagnarmi
e moltiplicato Oh no io adesso come
facciamo lo dobbiamo regalare a qualcuno
no lo tengo io tu già ne hai uno li
chiamerò gismo e gisnam non lo so non mi
sembra una buona idea
possono carinissimi Sì è vero sono super
carini ma sono due non ti preoccupare
non farò più nessuno di questi errori
chiediamo Merlino cosa ne pensa Merlino
Cosa ne pensi
dei sogni non si accorge di nulla
Merlino Facciamo che decide Merlino
Allora Merlino posso tenerli Cosa ne
pensi
mi ha davvero una brutta idea però ha
detto che va bene purché lo lasciamo
dormire senti ora dobbiamo fare merenda
con il tè delle cinque io i miei Dream
League Come si chiamano quindi lasciarci
tranquilli Ok ciao Buonanotte Merlino
Oh proprio amici
[Musica]
No non si mangiano Merlino
mangiano
Grassi devi trattarli come se fossero
dei tuoi fratellini ok
[Musica]
mmm
Ecco fatto questo è per voi e questo per
me salute
[Musica]
Sono contenta che ti piace tanto questo
tè ghismo Tu sarai Chi è il tuo business
Sì Ah c'è anche qualcosa da mangiare ci
sono questi biscotti visto che vi piace
tanto mangiare mi sembra proprio come
Vitale Ecco qua un po' di biscottini
piano piano ce n'è per tutti ma
Li avete mangiati tutti
hai visto Merlino questi mangiano più di
te
io di Vitale forse non è strano
Merlino Si è offeso perché non ho dato a
lui i biscotti
Merlino sei geloso ma loro sono così
carini Guarda sembrano così buoni e
dolci Anche se hanno mangiato tutto
Beh allora come procede
abbiamo fatto merenda con i biscotti
invece è bello I biscotti
ma sono finiti tutti
purtroppo sì ero rimasto più niente
avevano molta fame avevano molta fame si
sono mangiato tutto Mi dispiace lo so
che erano i tuoi biscotti ma loro
avevano molta fame Sai mangiare
tantissimo quasi più di Merlino
Speriamo di trovare subito una famiglia
che li adotti Allora noi non possiamo
mica tenerli due Mangioni in più così
Certo che possiamo tenerli questi sono
miei sono i miei vecchissimi non li
daremo proprio nessuno Non lo so è che
ho proprio brutto presentimento
[Musica]
È arrivata l'ora di andare a dormire
vuoi dormirete qua mi raccomando fate da
bravi
Ecco la vostra copertina
Buonanotte gismo buonanotte gisma a
domani
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Dove siete
Ciao bellino che ci fai lì sul tavolo
C'è questo qua Merlino
popcorn
merendine snack
sei stato tu Merlino
Merlino Sei stato tu a prendere queste
cose dalla cucina Tu fai chismo Vitale
Vitale
Vieni subito qui
che è successo che cosa stavi facendo
stavo lavando i piatti guarda che cosa
ho trovato qua nel tavolino della TV
Qualcuno ha mangiato questa notte è
pieno di popcorn snack
merendine Qualcuno ha mangiato di
nascosto Stanotte sei stato tu vero che
si sta mangiando tutti i Popcorn Sì ma
Merlino non può nel cassetto della
cucina come ha fatto o forse l'hai fatto
tu ieri non ti ricordi mi sembra che
stai cercando una scusa per quello che
hai fatto tu e cioè andare in cucina
aprire il cassetto a mangiare tutto di
nascosto e poi Hai pure lasciato le
prove qui che non sei stato tu allora
Che cos'è questa tracce di cioccolato
cosa stavi facendo
dopo di cioccolato non l'ho fatto
apposta però il cioccolato questo qui
mica Quelle sono cose salate vedi sono i
Popcorn i crackers Io sto mangiando il
cioccolato No queste cose qui
effettivamente lì non c'è cioccolato
tutto
[Musica]
sono spariti al piano di sopra non
c'erano nel loro letto quindi devono
essere possono essere stati loro possono
essere stati loro a mangiare tutto
questa notte c'era scritto chiaramente
di non dargli mai da mangiare dopo
mezzanotte dobbiamo trovarli subito se
hanno mangiato dopo mezzanotte potrebbe
essere successo qualcosa di pericoloso
quindi cerchiamoli gli
smaltismo Merlino tu hai visto qualcosa
Dove siete forse qua dentro si
troveranno nascosti dentro l'armadio No
forse hanno mangiato dopo mezzanotte e
quindi sono scomparsi magari era quello
il pericolo se mangiano dopo mezzanotte
scompaiono potrebbe essere Non lo so Mi
è venuta un'idea proverò ad attirare
Game con i Popcorn
Disney
Dove siete
Merlino Aiutami a cercarli dove sono
Dimmi dove sono Tu probabilmente avrai
visto tutto vero Ma sei solo interessato
ai popcorn Dimmi dove sono andati
che c'è Merlino c'è qualcosa là dietro
sto trovando che cosa è successo che
cosa ti hanno fatto Ma dov'è ghisma Beh
per fortuna abbiamo ritrovatodismo ma
ora ci manca l'altro Gremlins da
ritrovare e se ha mangiato Dopo
mezzanotte potrebbe essere molto
pericoloso
[Musica]
dove sei sisma
e si fuori ghisma
dove sei gli smart
Kim Perché non mi dici dove è andata
Dimmi dove si nasconde se era
spaventatissima come te
stai guardando l'armadio
perché guarda l'armadio
non mi sembra che ci sia niente dentro
Kiss Ma è tutto buio
continuiamo a cercare
[Musica]
forse l'unico modo è fare una trappola
ma mi sono dimenticata di dirvi Mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace
questo video entro 5 secondi 5 4 3 2 1
via tempo scaduto e se non mi seguite
ancora su Instagram andate a seguirmi il
nome Anita Stories e se volete Seguitemi
anche su Tik Tok il nome è sempre Anita
Stories Secondo voi dove si sarà
nascosta devo continuare a cercare
sicuramente ai Gremlin mi piace
tantissimo mangiare quindi potrebbe
essere in cucina non ci avevo pensato
potrebbe essere in cucina andiamo a
controllare subito Okay andiamo in
cucina Dai magari sarà qua in cucina
Hai sentito quel rumore
Guarda l'armadio l'armadio si è aperto
da solo a meno che non l'ho aperto
Merlino Merlino hai aperto tu l'armadio
Che cosa stai guardando
Merlino è come se stesse guardando
qualcosa di invisibile
Merlino hai aperto tu l'armadio Com'è
possibile che si è aperto da solo
Mi raccomando qui sopra un fantasma ma
non c'è niente
hai visto
l'armadio beh appena uscito dall'armadio
non sarà andata lontano deve essere qua
vicino
[Musica]
non c'è niente qua
Mannaggia Vitale dove sei vitale
Che cos'è quello
Merlino hai visto anche tu se qualcosa
dietro al divano
No non c'è niente ma mi sembra di aver
visto un orecchio che spuntava da qua
sta succedendo qualcosa di strano Forse
è inutile continuare a cercare chisma se
vorrà tornerà Beh prima o poi le verrà
fame Quindi tornerà Per forza non è
verosmo
è un po' strano che tipo terrorizzato
Vabbè ma dov'è finito Vitale Vitale
forse è salito su
Vitale
super è finito mi sono spaventata ho
preso la scatola per fare la trappola
così lo possiamo prendere possiamo fare
una sorta di trappola rifugio con la
scatola così possiamo riprenderlo e
riprenderci cura di lui esatto
Eccoci qua nella nostra cameretta come
possiamo fare per preparare questa
trappola mettiamo il cibo dentro alla
scatola Ma poi dobbiamo tenere la
scatola aperta potremmo mettere un
bastoncino Ok proviamo e speriamo che
funzioni Qua c'è ancora la ruota
dell'ultima Challenge la Challenge chi
apre più regali vince in cui abbiamo
perso tantissimi calendari dell'avvento
se non l'avete vista andate a vederla
dopo questo video
Merlino
non fate cibo metti Merlino vuole già
mangiare il cibo della Trappola no
Merlino non è per te è Pervinca è per il
Gremlin ho avuto un'idea per evitare che
gli Small Green rimanga dentro la
scatola magari noi non ce ne accorgiamo
ma metteremo questo pulsante metteremo
il cibo sopra così quando il jeans ma
prendere il cibo schiaccerà il pulsante
suonerà l'allarme e potremmo prenderla
subito che ne pensi di questa idea È
un'ottima idea passami subito l'allarme
mettiamo l'allarme qui Speriamo che
Merlino non mangi il cibo per il granny
Passami il cibo sembra molto interessato
Merlino non è per te mettiamo anche il
cibo sopra l'allarme così quando lo
prenderà suonerà
Speriamo che funziona e ricopriamo il
tutto copriamo il tutto con questa
semplice trappola no Merlino No questo
non è per te
andiamo andiamo
Merlino con noi ok La trappola è pronta
ora andiamo via da questa cameretta e
speriamo che funzioni Speriamo
Mira
Merlino
non distruggere la trappola andiamo
Merlino andiamo dai oh io un metodo per
distrarre Merlino questi croccantini a
forma di Ossa Merlino Guarda No
la trappola funziona almeno abbiamo
testato che la trappola punta un po' la
funziona e la testata a Merlino anche se
lui non è rimasto intrappolato perché
più furbo No guarda che cos'è qua i tuoi
biscottini preferiti seduto Bravo
Vieni qua vieni qua vieni qua
Giusto allora
adesso la risistemiamo Allora l'allarme
è rimasta a posto lo risistemiamo poco
poco così e poi andiamo a chiudere il
tutto così
perfetto sistemato tutto andiamo
Speriamo solo che la trappola funzioni
aspetterò qui pazientemente
[Musica]
l'allarme
devo andare a controllare
Che cos'è quella cosa là sotto la
scatola
provo ad alzare la scatola forse non è
una buona idea ma sono troppo curiosa
ghisma Merlino che faccio alza la
scatola apro la scatola forse non è una
buona idea ma devo scoprire se c'è
chisma qua dentro
sei tu
allora
[Musica]